no no I'm sry turn around get on the
ground get on the ground he I'm sry get
on the
ground a teenager is charged with
manslaughter after a Florida officer
collapsed and died following this
struggle don't walk away from me no no
Sor don't pull away from me I'm checking
you for what get your hands away from
your no stop no stop a portion of the
body cam video released online from the
May 19th incident captures Ace police
officer calling in dispatch and
approaching a teen who can be seen
walking outside a local motel in St
Augustine Florida
stop 422 St
Jes 102 s 13p spaic mail white T-shirt
uh black shorts super 3 16 3576 you me
stop
yeah I'm the teen in the white T-shirt
was identified as 19-year-old Veria
agular Mendes an indigenous Mayan Farm
worker originally from Guatemala agular
Mendes was reportedly on the phone with
his mother when approached by St John's
County Police Sergeant Michael kunovich
when Sergeant kunovich begins to
question agular Mendes the teen
expressed he did not understand what was
being said because he couldn't speak
English okay why when I was driving
around oh
stop okay but why did you get up and
walk away huh when you saw me you get up
and walked away why yeah why
[Music]
drink where are you staying huh where
are you staying
sleeping here yes why aren't you eating
inside
what okay I've got I've got somec okay
do you have any ID and identification
license what ID
identification in the room yeah okay
what's your first name huh your first
name
okay do you have any weapons on you huh
you have any weapons on you no well you
know what that is turn around let me
look turn around turn around when
Sergeant kunovich attempts to search
agular Mendes for weapons the teen still
struggles to understand the officer and
that's when the incident takes a turn
don't walk away from me no no Sor don't
pull away from me I'm checking you for
what get your hands away from your no no
no no stop no no I'm sorry I'm sorry hey
[Applause]
another officer arrives on scene to
assist kunovich as agular Mendes
repeatedly can be heard saying I'm
sorry
turn get
on get on the
ground the body cam video then ends
after that moment Sergeant kunovich died
from a heart attack in agular Mendes was
charged with murder his charges were
later reduced to aggravated manslaughter
of a police officer which in Florida
carries a Max sentence of 30 years in
prison this is a unique case because
you're talking about foreseeability
you're talking about proximate cause
issues here and so it's going to be a
tough case for any prosecutor I spoke
with Palm Beach County State Attorney
Dave aronberg while his office was not
responsible for charging Mendes agular
with manslaughter he understands why the
charges were brought against him when I
first saw it though I I know the state
attorney up there and he's a good guy
who obviously wants to do justice in
every case this case I do think can get
to a jury I think he has a good faith
basis to file the charges it just would
be an uphill battle because it depends
exactly on what was foreseeable and how
much the medical examiner could say that
the scuff
led to the officer's death but in the
end the state attorney has left with an
individual who is an undocumented
immigrant who resisted arrest with
violence and led to the death of law
enforcement officer so you can see why
the state attorney there was uh quick to
file charges the question is whether
those charges will stick well every
Community is different we're we all
represent different uh places here in
the State of Florida and what would lead
to a conviction up in that District in
uh St John's County valua county that
circuit up there is different than what
would lead to a conviction in Palm Beach
County I can say that that case would be
unlikely to result in a conviction here
in Palm Beach County that would be
something to influence our filing
decision because as State Attorneys we
have to have a good faith belief that we
can get a conviction Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt and knowing judges and juries here
in our community it would be very
unlikely that we could get a conviction
or anything above resisting arrest with
violence but keep in mind that resisting
arrest with violence is a felony in
Florida it's a third deegree felony and
so there are legitimate grounds to file
felony charges here's what we didn't see
from the body cam video according to a
police report from the incident agular
Mendes had a folding pocket knife inside
his shorts pocket while the body cam
video doesn't show the knife agular
Mendes allegedly grabbed the knife from
his pocket and that's when the officers
tried to disarm him agular Mendes
reportedly told the officer he needed
the knife to cut up watermelon seemingly
referring to his job according to
reports the struggle lasted 8 minutes
during that time the officers pinned and
pushed the teen to the ground as the
teen begged for his family police
reportedly held him in a choke hold and
stunned him with the taser six times in
2 minutes right after the altercation
the the teen is placed into cuffs and
put into a patrol car and that's when
kunovich suffered a heart attack
according to an autopsy report Sergeant
kunovich died from natural causes after
suffering from cardiac dysthymia which
may have been a result of severe heart
disease the autopsy also reportedly
noted kunovich had a prior heart attack
or Heart and Lung deterioration due to
smoking I I understand why The Advocates
are upset because he's facing 30 years
in prison and the medical examiner ruled
that the officer's death was of natural
causes if the officer's death was not
foreseeable if it was not proximate
cause of the resisting then I don't see
how they're going to get a conviction
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt for that
first-degree felony but at the very
least there is a good faith basis and I
think enough evidence to sustain a
conviction for resisting arrest with
violence even though there is a language
barrier uh the individual did resist and
I think that's something that a jury
would have to to sort out so here's what
we know about vilo agular Mendes
according to a previous motion filed by
his public defender agular Mendes
arrived to the US two years ago at 17
years old to provide a better life for
his family he was held at a Federal
Detention Facility for minors until his
release he later traveled to St
Augustine to work at the local farms
while agular Mendes learned some Spanish
previously his native language is maam
on the night of his arrest he was
reportedly outside the Super Eight Motel
where he stayed with other migrant
workers eating a outside and talking
with his mother when approached by
Sergeant kunovich according to reports
officers recovered cash a cell phone
lighter pocket knife and his motel room
card from agular Mendes well the
question is whether the officer probably
caused him make an arrest and it seems
like he did but then the question is can
he make the stop does he have Reasonable
Suspicion to make a stop and that's
something that would be litigated in the
courts that's something that the court
can decide that there was not the basis
to even stop him in the first place but
so so far the fact that he's being held
without bond shows that the judge has
already found that probable cause
existed to make an arrest and because
you have the immigration status and
because you have the language barrier
he's being held longer than someone else
would without a hearing of because of
all the extenda
circumstances I I I understand what the
Advocates are saying it I can understand
looking at this from the outside that it
looks like something that is is not
justice but on the other hand prosecutor
is is had a good faith basis to
prosecute this case as a resisting
arrest with violence and I think based
on the fact he could pursue it as
something more but now there's an
indefinite pause on the case during a
December competency hearing Aguilar
Mendes was declared by the courts as
mentally incompetent to stand trial due
to his lack of understanding of the US
criminal justice system and with the
issue of Competency at play aronberg
says there's a brief flaw as that system
was set up for people with mental
illness not people who have to deal with
a language barrier the craziest cases
seem to always happen in
Florida I have faith in the system and
the process I know it can be very
frustrating to people because of the
delays but the reason why this defendant
is behind bars awaiting trial is because
he's undocumented and also
because there's a language barrier that
he speaks a language where there is not
an interpreter in that area the the
issue I would have is that the
competency system which is designed to
send someone to a hospital to get
competent while they await trial is
really designed for people with mental
illness it's not really designed for
someone who's not competent because they
don't speak the language if he was a
defendant down here in South Florida
there would be an interpreter available
for him a Mayan interpreter but because
he's in North Florida where there is no
interpreter available it complicates
matters and I would hope that a judge
could have a hearing so that they could
determine whether or not he's able to
stand trial or get a m interpreter so
that he's not just kept Behind Bars
indefinitely and if there was an
instance where there's not a mom or M um
interpreter what would happen in that
case eventually he would be let free if
he's not restored to competency then he
would be led free that's what happens
even cases of mental illness we we don't
keep people Behind Bars indefinitely
through her life unless have been
convicted of something and if there's
nothing that can um help him understand
the proceedings around him then he would
be set free but look he's already served
like eight to nine months and that's
more than he probably would have
received even if he was found guilty of
that third degree felony of resisting
arrest with violence until the issue of
Competency is worked out agular Mendes
will remain behind bars with no bond a
judge put a pause on his case until
agular Mendes can receed the proper help
before his case can move forward
reporting for law on crime I'm Elizabeth
Milner